if you've ever invested in the financial
markets i'm sure you've heard of these
big bad institutions called market
makers we're often told horror stories
that these guys have full control of the
market and that they manipulate it on a
constant basis to suck out as much money
as possible from the average retail
investor
likely the most famous example of a
market maker allegedly abusing their
power to influence a stock was during
the gamestop run when citadel apparently
pressured robin hood to halt the buying
of gamestop this portrayal has given
market makers a pretty bad reputation
and to be honest most market makers
don't deserve anything better
however the concept of market makers was
not invented out of bad faith
in fact market makers were supposed to
help markets run smoothly and
efficiently both for retail investors
and institutional investors
and you could argue that they still
accomplish this despite their bad
reputation
but who exactly are market makers what
exactly do they do and why do so many
investors despise market makers
starting off with the basics let's take
a look at what exactly a market maker is
a market maker is simply an individual
or institution that partners with an
exchange to increase liquidity on the
exchange the way they accomplish this is
by acting as both buyers and sellers for
all the securities that are traded on
the exchange here's the thing there's
not always people out there that are
willing to buy the stock you're selling
or sell you the stock that you want to
buy
this is especially true if you're trying
to sell or buy a massive amount of stock
with low volume and this is where market
makers step in
these guys will guarantee to buy or sell
the given stock at prices that are just
below or just above the market price
these guaranteed offers are called the
bid and ask price for example let's take
a look at gamestop's bid and ask prices
when the stock was
136.50
and
at
as you can see the bid price is 136
dollars and 12 cents and the ask price
is
136.55 cents
this means that a market maker is
willing to buy gamestop from you for
136.12 cents right now regardless of
whether there's a buyer on the other
side similarly a market maker is willing
to sell gamestop to you for 136.55
regardless of whether there's a seller
on the other side
if you put in a market order to buy or
sell shares as fast as possible these
are the prices that they'll execute at
if you look closer at these bid and ask
prices you'll see that there's a phrase
at x1 right next to either price this
indicates how many shares market makers
are willing to buy or sell at these
prices
generally their offers are measured in
units of 100 shares because this is the
minimum that market makers are required
to offer at any given time clearly
market makers aren't willing to offer
more than the minimum with gamestop but
with more established stocks their
offers are much more substantial with
apple for example market makers are
currently willing to buy 3900 shares at
149.99 and sell 19 700 shares at 150
as you can see it these offers make it
very difficult for the average retail
investor to ever run into a liquidity
problem and this makes sense given that
that's the main purpose of a market
maker
alright so market makers aim to make
financial markets more efficient and
liquid but how exactly do they make
money
well the answer is obvious market makers
never actually buy or sell at the
current market price
their offers to buy are always slightly
lower than the market price and their
offers to sell are always slightly
higher than the market price so they're
automatically in profit the second that
they execute your trade but here's the
catch this profit is just on paper as a
retail investor you can easily translate
paper profits to realize profits by
buying or selling shares to market
makers but for market makers to realize
their gains they actually have to find
someone who is willing to take on the
other side of the trade for high volume
stocks this is not too difficult
and that's why the difference between
the bid and the ask price is just one
cent for apple but for a stock like
gamestop the spread is far larger at 43
cents while spreads make it easier for
market makers to flip their shares for a
profit this is not always possible
because stocks aren't exactly stable
in fact they're really stable and
they're usually going up or down and
meaning that there's an imbalance
between buyers and sellers and given
that market makers always have to be
willing to buy or sell it regardless of
whether security is running up or
selling off market makers inevitably end
up with a long or short position
themselves but this is okay because
market makers don't actually try to make
a profit on every single share they buy
or sell because that's simply impossible
rather they focus on the average price
of their net position and ensure that
it's favorable relative to their current
market price for example if a market
maker were to accumulate a long position
their goal would be to ensure that their
average price is less than the market
price conversely if a market maker were
to accumulate a short position their
goal would be to ensure that their
average price is more than the market
price if at any point igf's become
untrue we'll see the bid ask pride and
actually widen as market makers pull
back and try to get back into a
profitable position if this is all the
market makers did there wouldn't be a
problem in fact market makers would
likely be appreciated for providing
liquidity and efficiency to the
financial markets however as you would
guess market makers often use their
leverage and influence to manipulate the
markets to make even more money
given that market makers have been
around for decades they've gotten
extremely good at manipulating the
markets they use countless strategies to
move the markets in their favor but
we'll stick to the most common
strategies starting with the barrier and
the bull rating this is likely the
simplest form of manipulation as market
makers are essentially just buying or
selling large amounts of securities to
move the price in a specific direction
but what makes this strategy so powerful
is how strategically market makers use
it for example let's say a market maker
wants apple stock to fall maybe they
have a short position in the company or
they want to buy in cheaper what they'll
do is wait for apple stock to reach a
price at which there's a bunch of stop
losses and as apple nears this price the
market maker will go out and dump a
bunch of apple stock this will trigger
the stop losses which will cause a
domino effect of selling and fear and
before you know it the stock will be
down four or five percent giving the
market maker the perfect opportunity to
close their short positions or buy and
lower this same strategy works on the
other side as well
if a stock is approaching a critical
breakout level with a bunch of limit buy
orders the market maker can buy a good
amount of shares right underneath this
level and cause a buying frenzy this
buying frenzy won't last long though as
the market maker will be dumping their
positions into this strength causing the
price to drop back underneath the
critical level this is usually what's
happening when we see fake outs like
these another popular manipulation
tactic is spoofing the tape this is when
market makers put in phony orders into
the order book to mislead traders for
example let's say apple is trading at
101 dollars per share a malicious market
maker might go ahead and put in a buy
order for a million apple shares at 100
per share
seeing this massive order retail traders
are often led to believe that a massive
whale is buying apple at 100
if they're willing to put in so much
money into apple surely they must know
something right
well they don't but regional investors
don't know that and they'll go ahead and
put in their own buy orders at one
hundred dollars right before the stock
actually hits 100 though the market
maker will cancel their order meaning
that it's just the retail investors who
are left buying apple in this scenario
the market makers were able to add
significant buying pressure to apple
without spending a single cent
themselves they can use this same
strategy to the upside as well and
create a bunch of selling pressure yet
another manipulation tactic that market
makers use is the new cycle and one of
the most prominent examples of this is
earning season even the most seasoned of
traders don't trade during earnings
because they know that market makers are
on full control they might sell the
stock into a strong earnings report and
buy this talk as soon as the report
drops or they might sell the stock into
a weak earnings report and sell it even
more the second the report drops this is
when you hear things like buy the rumor
and tell the news or sell the rumor and
by the fact while these phrases sound
smart you usually have no clue what the
market makers have planned until it's
already too late but unfortunately
beginners often buy or sell thinking
they know what they're doing and usually
they just get obliterated one thing to
note though is that all these
manipulation tactics only hurt you if
you're trading and it's actually why
it's so hard to be a successful trader
in the first place if you simply stick
to buy and holding though you don't have
to worry about any of this
all of the manipulation tactics that
we've discussed so far have been around
for ages but something that's gained a
lot of attention in recent history is
payment for order flow payment for order
flow is when market makers pay
brokerages for the opportunity to
execute their trades this is one of the
primary methods that quote-unquote free
brokerages like robin hood make their
money the problem with this strategy
though is that its consequences are not
that favorable for the end user for
example brokerages should be trying to
get the best prices they can for you to
buy and sell your shares
traditionally brokerages shop around at
a bunch of market makers to get the best
quotes possible but when a brokerage
logs in with a market maker in return
for payment they're giving the market
maker a substantial pricing power the
market maker no longer has to offer the
best bid and ask prices instead they can
widen the spread to maximize their own
profits
this was actually a major problem in the
late 1990s when we first saw zero
commission brokerages gained popularity
at the time the smallest spread on these
brokerages was 12 and a half cents this
means that if you are selling 100 shares
you are losing out on as much as 12 and
50 cents clearly this is a conflict of
interest and that's why many countries
such as the uk australia and canada have
banned the practice
however the practice is still legal
within the us and the more and more
brokerages have turned the payment for
order flow in order to stay competitive
with other brokerages and these guys
generally make tens of millions if not
hundreds of millions every quarter just
from selling your order flow for example
in q2 of 2020 td ameritrade made 324
million e-trade made 110 million schwab
made 66 million and robert had made 180
million all from payment for order flow
and that's just the money that the
broker just made for the
the only reason that market makers are
paying these massive fees is because
they have even more to gain from the
practice as you can see theoretically
market makers aren't there to screw you
over they're actually meant to help you
sell and buy shares whenever you want
and if you're a long-term investor
market makers have likely helped you way
more than they've hurt you if you're a
short-term trader however it's a
completely different story market makers
make much of their money from
manipulating the markets and misleading
small-time investors into buying it and
selling it at the worst times possible
and while we can complain about them all
we want i think the best idea is to just
avoid the situation altogether and
simply dollar cost average into whatever
you're looking to buy but that's just
what i think do you guys think market
makers are a net positive or a net
negative comment that down below
also drop a like if you also prefer
avoiding market maker games altogether
and of course consider checking out our
international channels to watch the
videos in other languages and consider
to subscribe and see more questions
logically answered but until then i'm
hari and i'll see you guys on the next
one